gents this is amazing number one you
know you you're used to touring for long
long stretches of time I gotta say
thanks for doing this even though you're
feeling under the weather how do you how
do you deal with it like I know that you
guys are the utmost professionals but
what's the formula for kind of staying
healthy on the road especially when you
know you're feeling things coming on
is there one I think it's not any other
job is there do all the smaller things
get also snake beer I get lots of sleep
you don't worry about it too much yeah
definitely not talk about it too much
right so here we go I'm gonna bring you
out to talk all about it for another big
show when you guys you know are ready to
go on tour again you know you're gearing
up for it what's the emotion that goes
along with it cuz there are gonna be
sacrifices in life that you've got to
make to be on the road for a long time
but again you're used to it is sort of
the life of the elite right yeah we I
think we feel that we are Co the masters
of our destiny and the choices that we
make and we do this because we love it
we go out and we make the sacrifices
because we feel like they're the right
thing to do we wouldn't we wouldn't be
here right now unless this is very wants
to be so yeah there's like stuff that
goes on hold and pause and people are
being patient with us and at some point
we'll get back to the emails and yet in
the face time with our loved ones but
they know that's you know this is the
deal yes here we are
we wouldn't anything would change
anything about that we're very fortunate
mm-hmm and as you guys grow and change
and evolve as a band
what changes for you what's different
when you're going on tour like this time
around specifically
can we get in better weather better at
planning yeah better out kind of and
knowing what we want to do so we get
right in the weeds of everything from
the show design through to the microwave
energy yeah really a very hands-on and I
think we communicate better than we have
done in previous tours you know I have
been saying to people this is filled
fate this feels great early in the Delta
cycle where we're kind of just a couple
of months in so maybe we should see how
well we're really doing another year but
we aren't we all gonna be doing this for
at least another year or so and I'm just
getting this show out to as many people
as possible so they can experience this
creative output what do you think is the
biggest misconception that fans have
that spectators have about a touring
band like I've friends that tour and
they say they basically if you go to
amazing places and I'm like oh you saw
Munich that's amazing that not we
doesn't seem like what is what is the
biggest misconception you think
I'm not sure that it's party all the
time that's definitely not yeah I mean
there's certainly times when it's really
fun and the best times actually when we
get to when our crew get a bit of a
break because they work harder than
anyone else I know certainly hmm they do
my 89 today is consistently back-to-back
it's really intense and when they get an
opportunity to kind of come in for
dressing off to show and have a beer
that's really fun but the rest of the
time is kind of yeah trying to maximize
sleep and trying to travel well yeah
it's not as nice but for people who come
to shows of course that's their night
out in the week so you kind of feel like
you have to match their energy certainly
kind of maybe before and then certainly
on stage but then afterwards people like
cool that's part you know well they
always say that you know the crowd gives
you energy so in a day when you're
feeling kind of you know down or hoja
it's not that you don't ever want to do
it but let's say you're in Toronto and
the crowd is just giving you everything
that's how much of a difference does it
actually make massive amount of
difference yeah yeah and actually you
can tell I think you can tell different
crowds by place you know they can places
you go yeah Canadian crowds to us have
always has been unbelievably generous
yeah
and energetic and we don't just say that
everywhere we go I mean we've been lucky
at us
if you chose this little East Coast run
that we've done where crowds have felt
particularly generous especially right
at the beginning of putting out of the
mouth cause people don't know the songs
as well hmm
well you shouldn't expect grass and no
songs as well it's only been three weeks
since it came out and yet they're
singing them back to us you know but
almost as much energy and passion as the
songs have been around for ten years
yeah you know so for that we're pretty
great for the moment are you still
surprised by that but the idea that when
you see a crowd people have never even
seen you before or say you perform live
and they're still singing your songs
back to you I imagine when you're you're
a young band if they have the first time
you're out wow I can't believe this
happening and you're here you know your
fourth album and you're getting that
same sort of energy same response from
crowds that still surprise you yeah
there's always at least one moment but
no
multiple moments in the show every night
when it's like what in it really kind of
can take your breath away or like you
tear up just because I think one of the
great pleasures were playing is larger
settings like the arena environment is
it's overwhelming just the the sheer
volume not just all your audible volume
but the visual volume of like people
gathered like that it's incredibly
though just a heartwarming that the
power of congregation and togetherness
is a cool thing and and the way we've
been touring this album is right in the
middle of it all you know we have the
the stage set up in the middle of the
room so we just get that energy from all
these individuals who come to form this
beautiful collective it's pretty cool
I'm curious about the beginnings of an
album for you guys there specifically
for Delta is there a moment when you go
okay time to start writing new one or is
there music kind of happening all the
time over the course of years and years
before you even start to decide like to
put something together officially like
how does that work yes if it was
snowball yeah it does start at some
point you can't really figure out quite
where mm-hmm but maybe yeah and then it
starts rolling and rolling and gathering
yeah
yeah it's it's I think we've got for the
stage it was really late with Delta
where we got the stage were like this is
a definable piece of work because we had
so so many songs we had like 30 odd take
five songs to try and and none of them
were really in a finished state but
we're just writing and writing writing
and so we can't write enough yeah this
is keep going back and keep writing and
then eventually we all got a sense of
where we felt like okay now let's record
something yeah and then we started
recording and writing a bit more and
then they were like okay well let's just
record these songs and put them out
because they enter like a family and
then February we're going back to try
and finish off the rest with all of your
different I guess points of view you
know for different brains for different
hearts how do you know what direction to
take an album like people talk about
Delta like this is a new sound but not
not brand new like a different sort of
take on what you guys do how do you know
what to do and when do you say yeah this
is the new sort of thing that we're
doing we talk about it and then we play
it to each other yeah that's basically
it that's it yeah
and yeah we can discuss it like lots and
we did but then eventually we just gotta
get in studio play it hmm and play it to
each other and try a different shop and
each other up and you know use an
amazing soundboard like um like all that
work we're evolution swirling and then
you kind of find your way through it
yeah at least and then you put it away
and do the next one yeah um this song
being about so many different aspects of
your lives
right it's every song personal in a way
even if it's a story about someone
fictional is it still about you is still
about things that you've been going
through yeah as you say even if the
actual subjects is someone else mm-hmm
it does where is all of this homes are
interweaved into our lives and
we like that because it it just makes it
feel real and I think we're particularly
any of us are particularly good at kind
of writing concept music or heavy like
just there's a lot of wonderful
musicians out there who can create art
that isn't personal but we use I think
from our point of view we see it as a as
a means of expression it's a kind of
reflect upon something or someone or
whatever a scenario and it's great it's
a powerful thing for that and I think
people connect with us on that basis and
we connect with them you know similarly
as we were talking about before people
sing along with the song sometimes they
they feel better some are on t why we
enjoy seeing these songs in mass
congregational you know that has that
how do you guys deal with the
expectation of a new album like people
have listened to your songs for years
and your song some parts of their lives
but graduated got married to have any
babies to hear to your music all that
stuff and knowing that you know you are
a part of their lives and in such a deep
way how do you deal with that sort of
expectation that people might be like oh
man what's this new album gonna give me
I've never really engage with that side
of it to be honest with you I've never
fully I don't know it's not denial I
don't think it's more just like I don't
lean into that bit you're gonna have to
not well certainly when you're creating
something new I think it's cool once
it's made and once it's out to hear
stories like that that's really cool
yeah but when you're making something
new I think if you have that in your
head you're screwed from the beginning
mmm how can you possibly you know have
that expectation in your mind that I
don't think we'd do it to reach people
we don't do it we don't write songs to
affect people we write them very
selfishly
and then it's kind of an amazing
beautiful accident of humanity that it
does affect someone else then our story
might resonate with someone else that's
cool and that's something to be
celebrated and there's something to be
publicized
now which we dig right here out and make
the most
you know we make songs that are so
private as public as they can possibly
be
yeah which is such a weird thing to do
but I think if we started out thinking
about how can we affect people I just
think we wouldn't do it very well
is it weird when you you've written a
song and you focused on it in a certain
way like it's part of your life or it's
a part of your own story
and it goes out there and it gets
interpreted in a way that you're you
never expected yeah totally yeah there's
a lot lots of examples of that
especially with our band and I know that
we've got some other bands and we kind
of relish that yeah that's kind of cool
that that music and art can be
interpreted in different ways is
beautiful to us and what draws more
people than we ever expected to minister
to it into the social sphere of what
we're doing which is cool but we get
told that our songs are about all sorts
of things all the time yeah well that's
nothing to do that but that's cool if it
means that to you it was it's not
something really dark well at what point
in the creation of a song do you share
with someone other than just you guys
because there's something you go to you
and go like it's good do you think this
is too much like who do you guys talk to
you about that
so we were a great friend and manager
who's been with us since the beginning
and he's he's kind of a part of that
inner just slightly outside of the four
of us thanked him and then of course the
producer when we're making the record
and then sometimes our friends and
friends and family and I know your
brother's a great soundboard and you
know we have actually during the making
of day also we had quite a few friends
family and people we had never met they
just sound boarding and it's is helpful
before you go to a complete wide lens to
get that feedback and know but I did
when you when you asked that question I
did think about him and he's been a he's
been a great part of our journey is is
he the guy that can tell you
this isn't working and you don't you
trust them and you believe them identity
but I feel this feeling around pulling
in that paperwork and say 19 yeah yeah
yeah so you know what are you looking
forward to moving forward with this tour
and then sharing Delta with a new way to
the rest of the world
Wow or just the beginning you know yeah
just a couple weeks in this is the first
birth you know we've been out six months
worth of touring but wouldn't it to us
thing for a couple years so and try
being in and out of the studio in
between the tour dates as well so I
think we're just excited people to get
to know the record a bit more it's quite
then its record it's like an hour over
an hour of music there's a lot there
yeah and yes so well I think I'm looking
forward to people hearing it more and
then coming the shows hopefully between
now and a couple years time we will feel
like we've kind of been on the Delta
right together and ready for the next
thing you know